yeah hello and welcome to this video yet
another tea session I don't yet have if
the tea ready has to sit there for a
couple of minutes but I figured I might
as well start the video anyway so um
let's get a game going and I'm really
going for the increment I really like
that a lot more so with less hectic it
was also positive if you on doing this a
little bit longer blitz games like 5 + 3
I I like that actually it's just
difficult to get a game I can try this
after this one see if we get something
there yeah this is a funny way funky way
for black to play against the the
English opening have done this quite a
bit
one idea is that white sometimes
prematurely castles with 92 and a short
castle and then h5 is very dangerous it
looks like white is not going for this
in this game he's delaying this a little
bit now 97 has a drawback not a drawback
but after castles I cannot play h5 @ h5
s effectively
you
yeah
good tried the
will not cancel now because quite
obviously I was a taking C form but
maybe I can play like this now this is a
typical one is going 495 stopping d5 so
came well display he will not be able to
to castle easily
Ruby aids also fairly normal my ideas to
play b5 to undermine his some position
down so interesting
b5 not sure about this
five now and ultimately after taking on
c4 it's not clear if this helped
mmm interesting there are a couple of
interesting ideas in this position I can
flame 98 that's the conservative way to
do it and then play c6
you
[Music]
like years I cannot Castle and what
about this for example it's a little bit
uncommon strategically speaking this is
not a theoretical position maybe it has
been reached before but not to my
knowledge and I would be surprised if
exactly this has been played before but
is it it's an interesting motif going
away here so they cannot take on e7 and
I'm still on that pawn so he cannot
castle and I dearly came the question is
do I want to take because the knight can
take this is a little bit awkward
okay so just here now Knight takes
Knight takes I'm still on age three
interesting position
so now if I go c6
does he have something like b6 is that
strong
it's odd
c 6 b 6 ticks takes
judge could be it could be good for
white b6
okay I'm a little bit down on time and
increment notwithstanding you should not
fall on so much behind okay so you place
the the normal move let's aim
nice made quite a bit of progress on the
on the queenside
now I should probably move this away
out from from this bishops influence and
maybe Bishop c5 was a good move actually
mmm it's a bit of a shame I could have
thought about this for a moment
ship c5 made some sense
I'm not sure but may you can are you how
useful this a seven bishop is
you
okay creative it's a creative way to
cover h3
so that you can
castle
looking at e5 it's an interesting move
I cannot play d5 at the moment so I
probably have to jump back again to g6
it's a little bit of a back-and-forth
I won't you go d5 next
so okay
hmm I didn't
and probably I didn't think of this
position concretely enough didn't really
think about this move just thought okay
I should generally speaking clay d5 but
I didn't think about 94 as a reply
well let's see I mean I don't think I'm
in such bad shape every piece is playing
and I got the central tension now so
c-file is ultimately opening now I can
take play Bishop c5 trying to trade this
bishop
I wonder if he will avoid the trade
he's got a bit of pressure on the d5
pawn
maybe we should be too is a good choice
looks better than trading
mind
Thomas has something special that you
can do but I'm not aware of
don't see it
what's going on here that's a long time
some kind of it's a connection problem
right
or something else oh that's a shame
that's it's really interesting position
yeah and yeah that's a bit of a shame
this is an interesting position um I
would assume that it is roughly equal
but I'm not sure maybe we should be too
is good for an advantage let me just
quickly check what the engine says yeah
Bishop b2 is is a small advantage like
0.4 or something yeah this is what I
thought if anything he has to keep the
bishop pair here and play this should be
to move and now something like we should
be six yeah White has the bishop here
that is nice really it it looks nice but
b5 is a little bit weak and if if I can
somehow manage to play em yeah if I
somehow can manage to trade those I
would be fine but um yeah it's it is a
bit better for white there's no way
around that ISM I don't know something
happened on his end maybe a complete a
problem or he got distracted by
something that came up and I have had
many games losing back in the day when I
was playing on the center of the ICC
like a long time ago at that time I am
yeah really relied a lot on yeah food
that I ordered too much to my place like
fast food and don't do that anymore and
so often there they would have the
doorbell ringing and then other pizza is
ready and then I would lose the game so
on top of not eating well I also lost
chess games okay not happening anymore
but it happened to quite a bit back in
the day I got a five plus three
interesting okay it didn't have a rating
some kind of rating filter so my
opponent is a little bit lower than
usual I usually have 2200 filter active
so this is five plus three this is
really a bit longer so I'm sticking with
my default repertoire for white which
released in June the keep it simple
deform it really served me well I mean
I've played it quite a bit in tournament
chess but are not in blitz and pull it
and so and the beauty of this is that
you can simply - out the first couple of
moves really quickly pretty much
regardless what they do and this is for
example a line that scores really
heavily because many players don't know
that D takes you form it's the best
movement everything else is kind of not
questionable would be too strong but
certainly very comfortable this is one
of those lines that is very comfortable
now one at one point is that here after
C takes he will probably play it takes
93 we now have transposed to a tirage
defense to the to the Queen's Gambit but
in a suboptimal way for black because
black has taken on d4 a little bit too
early and this means that this
particular line with Bishop e3 is now
pretty good for white it is not clear
that black can equalize anymore probably
you cannot it's tough anyway in the best
lines for black in the tirage there are
some variations that might be okay but
it's not not easy to do but this
particular case is known to be very
advantageous for white and one reason is
that you can get this position if black
is absolutely precise you can get this
position as black with the tempo up with
the move h6 already played and now he
does not have h6 plate and we will see
the difference shortly I can play this
move now and this is something that it's
not possible if you imagine the same
same position with black having aged six
inserted obviously Bishop g5 doesn't
work but here it does and the
consequence can be pretty grave
I just have to check this now because
quite often you can instantly win or get
a better position here by going one
motif is Knight X is 6 ft x is six 90 x
t5 yeah this is sometimes working on
better set 96 Fe Bishop f6 Bishop f6 95
85 Bishop b5 check King moves Bishop c4
winning a piece but it's got b5 at the
end of this line yeah so that doesn't
work the other move that often works is
Knight f5 and I think I'm going to do
this Knight f5 now I'm the point is that
I'm on this and this makes the pin even
more problematic now my actual threat is
to take on e7 and then take d5 so the
pressure on them on the isolated pawn is
already extremely high what I did not
actually take into account is that he
can take the knight and take on b2 so
all that speech could be completely
useless because i blundered b2 I didn't
take it and probably he could have taken
it
huh okay so
huh anyway he didn't take it so let's
not waste time thinking about why but
rather see that we can can get somewhere
him now um how do we play the Queen
should move away from c2 I guess
the other thing is I can take only seven
of course
what quite sure where should put the
Queen currently d4 it's not a threat
yeah it's not a threat
can I place it somewhere
be 3des deform
like wimpy threes also plan with that
I'm not really awake yet
who
not really awake yet
93 can also be an idea
attacking d5
want to get the Queen out of that out of
that D that C filed really and I really
feel that it's a bit bit of an annoyance
that I am their queen bee one sometimes
an idea
and
we won Wow I really have to get fully
awake I'm thinking about stuff like
Queen b3 that's not going to end well
that overall session
mm-hmm okay
so where do we go
yeah Queen Queen to be one was my
original idea just wondering now now he
has some no he's in a full pin here
under on the Queen
I got something better
[Music]
yeah I still like this idea of playing
93 but Acquia also want to unpin so come
on I have to play movie I'm I'm just
basically falling asleep here during
this game it still blitz yeah even
though five plus three is slow it
doesn't mean that you should be so
sluggish
so this one yeah be take soruq shakes
hmm probably be takes
yeah I didn't do it well this is just
not a clear position
so I cannot immediately refute it here
and wind stuff I don't see how so
probably I'll move the bishop to f4
taking on f6 didn't didn't help at all
six queen TX III was immediately hanging
yeah Yaga here right
maybe that is renamed or it's just
referring to the first pilot who ever
broke the sound barrier Chuck Yeager
so now I got 96 ideas yeah this is also
interesting
so I think I think I'm just covering
this right let's cover it the bishop is
nicely placed here on e5 anyway
and later maybe on g4 there's a great
post and it covers c3 and it looks like
a good way to play maybe I had c4 though
ahead c4 okay that's crying over spilt
milk
everything's it's already already done
but now c4 right he cannot take it yeah
let's do it
I can always take on f6 if I'm attacked
here somehow like with Queen e7 or so I
can always take f6 and now
what do we play even c-5 comes into
consideration but taking is the most
obvious thing to do so let's take
now probably nights B takes t5 now I can
take f6 Knight takes and take on b7
this is netting a pawn
but no more yam come on I'm still behind
on the clock
why is this a decision okay still behind
on the clock so I'm going to speed up a
little bit and rookie - there's Lucas e8
this is an important one otherwise I
wouldn't be a pawn up and if he goes
Queen d2 I thought I thought Roxy - but
maybe then he can take on it - at the
end
huh that's a bit of a pain
you
yeah whatever
you
yeah now Luke check z2 is probably
playable
see a technical problem with it
or does he have something better even
yeah I'm currently yeah okay Quinn d3
right
queen d3 it keeps the pawn
why couldn't you take it to where I
didn't see why maybe just not
standing it right
let's trade this one
ah
it's
Hingham in the game and c4 will be a
good post
for getting over taking away important
squares for the night
now yeah
you
let's fix the g6 pawn he can play g5
after which I take and play G form okay
Bishop f7 here
the bishop is very good shed it covers a
- and it also covers this square so the
King cannot come up the board and the
knight is severely dominated very
important now I'm probably have to take
and then push push him back so that the
King can come up I need I need the king
there is just no way around this to
convert this advantage I also have the
right colored bishop it's a LightSquared
bishop for the a pawn this is not yet
super relevant but can become relevant
if he manages to trade down even more
than may I mean sold a pawn
plus the bishop is enough to win the
game this is an important thing
so
yeah Bishop f5 bishops are really strong
I mean in such a position here they're
just extremely strong
yeah I just have to yeah night-nights
jump around so to see six maybe
693
um no I don't want you
want to risk him is calculating that
honestly this is just a lot simpler to
play now King Khan King Kong King can
come to the six so I wonder maybe this
is the best way to do it and then just
go for the a porn
mm okay
I'm going to just winning after
capturing takes takes king Essex
cannot believe this it should be winning
you
I didn't didn't really count honestly
I should have counted how silly is that
it's just exactly the right the right
tempo Jesus
I just I just thought okay this is this
must win and it isn't that that's crazy
that's crazy that this is not winning
I didn't didn't didn't give away a
temple right
No
huh
yeah I mean maybe from a practical point
of view that was just a silly decision
because it's clear that I'm just winning
after Kings e4 I mean the bishop over
the night ending is an easy win yeah you
really should calculate him I mean okay
I just said 30 seconds but still you can
count that count that hmm okay
that was really silly
yeah and again that of course I should
win after having a huge advantage right
right out of the opening so I can go if
Roy yeah for a change and cut the French
yeah so let's play the exchange
and see what black is coming up with
yeah this is a line that I have featured
in my efore book and I'm always scoring
really heavily with it
black is simply not equal here just not
the case
let's see six and now white is very much
quicker on the farm and this is not easy
to handle for black at all
so yeah a couple of things
age three it's a bit of a lazy move but
not a bad move so it's going Knight g6
you can you can double on the e-file or
an interesting idea is also to expand on
the queenside with B 3 and C 4 I think
I'm going to double here
you
okay
you
you
I don't want to
about this and 95 I want this move in
position rook the 8th probably now
intending Bishop c8 after 95 otherwise
95 would net me the bishop am again
that's not the end of the world but it's
some not too bad
one thing I really recognized about the
play in those positions hittin the
exchange ranges and have played it
really a lot especially in blitz it is
very simple to play I mean with wide you
just have the obvious moves and you can
play quickly
this is often super handy in blitz chess
that you can just enjoy an advantage on
the clock and maybe it's just a little
bit yeah a little bit and this is often
just enough when you take them often the
time advantage on top
now I'm soup basically on my starting
time
and you you continuously have small
ideas like here f4 f5
came I don't want to trade absolutely
not even though it's not going to be a
bad position for me after I trade
honestly I have a form and then f5
how interesting I mean the way to not
trade would be g3 I know that this looks
extremely awkward but I will go a for
next and later expand huh that's a tough
one
I can also play f4 immediately for rupee
8mm it's not easy this is not an easy
decision I want to keep more on the
board
I know f4 g3 looks strange but I can get
the king up to f3 and g4 and then I'm
expanding and playing for playing for a
large space advantage
and this is not so easy like if he goes
f5 is a threat really winning I know I
can go Knight c7 that it's not winning
material yet so it's not a substantial
threat okay
so he just goes away immediately yeah
okay now um he's not threatening
anything here I think I'll go with one
trade then bring the king up I expect
him to play Ruby seven
he's defending this realm it just takes
him a little bit
nice it's like one minute down but you I
don't think you can heavily criticize
any of his decisions the the whole
endgame is a little bit more comfortable
for white but he's absolutely doing a
good job of limiting his
his very small disadvantage to that he's
not helping me in any way that's what
I'm trying to say okay this I'm not sure
now I can bring the night to e5
I really think he should have played
rookie seven before get rid of one look
okay
no I'm not trading
and this definitely helps I mean he's a
little bit boxed in
f-five is coming next now f5 is an
immediate threat Knight takes g6 with
Bishop takes d6 some threatening whoops
to take here check Bishop d6 and over
and the pawn is of course severely
limiting the knight on c7 and I'm
threatening g5 ooh
that is now a problem a real problem
so I can play 96 now right and win-win
they exchange
yeah I will do that right night it's not
technically super simple
[Music]
because he has a snotty form
yeah I will still do it I mean it's not
something you cannot do yeah the the the
line I was slightly concerned about is
didn't you see that at all
oh maybe
so FTX g6 was my concern Bishop d6 94
check this is not at least I thought not
a super trivial win
and have to take F takes there should be
77
yeah it should win but it's not not a
given that is so easy
new engine be enough
94 is the only move I think so I have to
take it otherwise he just takes the six
so takes and now I expect F takes
and Here I am this is the thing I will
ever win the exchange of course the
question is how exactly am i winning
this he will have a 5f form I don't have
to take immediately I can wait for a
moment and win a temple basically now I
guess look f1 stopping f5
if he can manage 96 f5f for dangerous
really dangerous pawns but I think that
this way he shouldn't be able to move
the F pawn in the first place and I have
an outside passer in the making it's
still not so easy I'm a king cannot go
to f4 okay so now I can go to f4 let's
do it
you
[Music]
mmm that's true
you
yeah this is what I meander I wasn't so
sure if this is a win
at least evidence and is a wind that is
easily figure it out figured out that
same I'm fairly certain that objectively
speaking it is a win but doesn't mean
that I can figure it out easily
and now the age point is very quick
you
and I think I think this should do the
trick this is promoting just promoting
you
hmmm that would be even be winning
without the rook it's just promoting on
its own
idea that King f6 is h7 yam there was
always a little bit of an advantage and
then all of a sudden he allowed this
advance I think I think once I had
the night only five that this is already
substantial yeah computer is on almost a
pawn for white
like a position like that it's just
always very comfortable you can easily
increase and and improve your position
and yeah so here I was happy that I got
got something long-term yeah this is a
tricky decision how to handle this I
wanted to avoid further trades by going
f4 this is debatable you can do many
things that I think a little bit better
even even taking should be a small small
edge what does the engine say yeah the
engine also confirms that this is a
small edge
so one thing that he definitely should
have done I think is when I went King f2
here he should go rookie 7 in my mind
it's the straightest of course this is
still better for a while yeah I have
more space and the bishop a average I
think it should be easier to defend with
Outlook the way it turned out that that
was really really awkward already now
it's 7 + f5 and now this is already
winning yeah as I thought because I'm
also threatening g5 f 6 and if that
happens it's it's curtains just over and
here yeah again this is a little bit of
a technical task but it should win you
to the outside outside passim yeah
computer basically confirms that is
complete win and here it's touchdown
already for the H pawn he cannot stop it
ok so let's go back to the starting page
and
one more of those maybe maybe yeah I got
them pretty quickly those games
now I have really got lots of criticism
for the exchange French in Eddie for
book
and somehow I always think that's a
little bit funny because I mean it
should be pretty much non-controversial
that that this is not a pet opening just
not admittedly the most ambitious one
okay so going to play a bit a bit of a
creative set up here with g6 stuff like
that I played
let's say 30 years ago now almost 30
years ago I was just joining a chess
club and maybe like 27 years ago there
lots of those g6 system in my
Jr yes
some of those g6 d6 systems are not bad
I mean they can be played even nowadays
in particular if you are not exactly
facing here the lag of Magnus if you
just play normal people and you can play
them those Jesus g6 system is actually
quite quite well ok so I'm taking this
and then trying to get a bit of counter
play here
sure he is pretty similar to an elegance
defense and the alekan so ever you have
the night on b6m and such a situation
quite often and here I've got I've got
it on a much better square e seven I
could have taken on F 3 and d 4 but B 7
was hanging so that wasn't so so great
I'm going to e7 here because Knight to
f5 later looks like a good choice
putting pressure on the pawn on d4 now
I'm actually threatening to win a pawn
and Bishop f3 Bishop f3 Bishop takes d4
just wince ascend the pawn form pretty
much nothing I guess
it's not such an easy decision for wine
you can play d5
I will probably take on a three and then
jump right in this is possible yeah I
just wonder what his ideas if I go age
six
this is technically covering the pawn
it takes Bishop takes Bishop before
Bishop takes his six wins apiece so I
couldn't grab on before but age six is
asking a somewhat inconvenient question
so he's basically creating a pawn
sacrifice here right after g5 I'm
winning the pawn the question is if it
is good
it's probably a slightly risky decision
to take this pawn it takes quite a bit
of time
you
to to snatch it
and I am I don't really like my position
after that it's so loose so g5 Bishop d3
bishop a3 Bishop a3 Bishop takes the
form hmm
it's a send upon
if your opponent gives you a center pawn
deform and you need a really really good
reason not to take it and I didn't see a
really good reason
so saying looks a bit bit loose and so
on
this is on izing good but it's a centre
pond
often if you have those unclear if you
have this notion that it could be a
little bit risky to take upon think
about what kind of pawn it is if it is a
sent upon it has to be a really good
reason to not to not take it
so honestly what exactly is wide
thinking about
maybe d5 is that somehow move I mean
I don't quite see why
you
I don't know Bishop d3 is just an
instant move there is no death no
sacrifice or anything like that of
course
the only move that you can possibly
consider is d5 counter-attack so now
after all this after this long speech
yeah I will take the pawn I mean you can
say maybe there's some I don't know
Queen b3 or whatnot so um I don't know
there is no apparent reason why I cannot
take it at least I didn't see any some
doing this and you can check me okay I
don't mind dad really King f8 g7 is not
an issue I'm on g7 anyway so I'm this is
actually looking better than castling
because the rook on h8 at least covers
aged six and so on then the big scare of
this position would be a knight coming
to f5 and this is what I have to make
sure that doesn't happen
if it would be my move I would strongly
consider to take the night
it's it's a tough decision but something
that I really would think about
even though as long as that Bishop is on
deform the night will not come to have
five yeah that's also clear and the
bishop only four is a very strong piece
now what does he want to play
you
I wonder before
if something like that would be
interesting okay I'm playing this
maybe 97 as a movie actually I only 97
you
ninety-seven does threaten night
and if I take it there is Queen f4 check
and maybe I can take it Quint you
forecheck f6 and then 96 it's probably
solid enough
b3m okay so b7 hangs I have to
[Music]
you have to cover it yeah probably yes
yeah let's covered
now is Sam anything concrete that you
threatening
I'd like to play some of their groupie
aid
let's go here
okay
tending to take on the fourth
I have rook e8 down
rupee aw Chieti can take on aid
and then something is hanging so let's
say rookie a rookie a rookie 8 Queen B 7
do I have something good after Queen B 7
mm nothing
[Music]
nothing really good
you
alternative would be Bishop e5
then probably a form
okay mmm not so happy about this
now f4 is the thing
you
King position is is now a little bit a
little bit airy really is night h5 now
is part of this position
you
you
me too need to get this organized
quickly trying to
stuff know this I didn't expect
and Kim that's centralized
now White has now a really good
compensation that that is the thing
about this g5 year you're always a
little bit shaky and this is this
shakiness that same has now materialized
but I still had to take the corners no
doubt in my mind that this was the best
move but the practical implications are
always there
okay
Ruki hives probably Bishop f6
you
night Knight e5 returns the pawn but I
don't want to do this just yet I'm
certainly okay after that
but
you
come on there's really no need yet to
return it
now 95 Queen moves Neji six
I think
you
he can probably just take it home
we
pin
and then
you
okay Luke f6 coming
of queen G for the
all my time
you
you
you
and this is probably not helping I'm
running right into the bishop check this
is very silly actually
you
you
okay I've got 18 seconds again this is
important ah he's on c3 arm and such a
[ __ ] while what a terrible game or I
completely lost the threat there at the
end and this plus three is irritating I
actually had time I didn't have to panic
there
ah
I actually thought this is the worst was
over really like here the worst is over
what I said said a misjudgment
why it's so terrible it's still terrible
in the way I mean I made a couple of
really silly moves
so yeah yeah I mean he can just take
this yeah they can just take this on f1
f5
yeah maybe I should have be more
practical there because like here 95 is
probably I mean okay he doesn't have to
take it maybe he just keeps this keeps
the pressure on
it is clear that here white has
definitely very good compensation my
King position is just shaky and maybe
this is the signal that I should have
done something else somewhere
because here
95 is actually good for what
it is risky it is risky I mean as I said
it is very principled to take the center
pawn and and basically call whites yeah
it's not a bluff really because he has
enough but some some things were strange
here like we should age for took him a
minute or so and this this took a minute
yeah d5 is a move d5 is a month yam so
the night takes comes into consideration
I thought about that briefly because
here who p8 could actually be good yeah
the night is strong and I'm under some
the Caesar seems to be this is better
right I have to take with the night
a bishop takes is not a very natural
move but I assembly simply didn't assume
they didn't evaluate this correctly
Kim this is some pretty strong
compensation it's really pretty strong
II could have taken all ready for a win
and this one
yeah okay it's it's not exactly trivial
yeah
twins
now this is made actually according to
the engine okay
yeah I'm lettin you yeah white has
extremely strong compensation adjust my
King position is so weak yeah
Oh
yoga seven was already made I mean I
really panicked yeah I have taught ahead
time there but okay I mean the position
is lost yet I cannot really cannot
really stop him from killing me no oh I
can take the Queen and he could have
taken my queen so what's going on here
that was really really weird sequence of
moves what
I really panicked here
creaform bishop c3 and now I can take I
can take the Queen I took the pawn what
this is an entirely bizarre game that's
really completely crazy if I take it
there is a check but there's no maid you
know it's no maid and yes he has a
perpetual but you cannot win that is one
of the weirdest games ever
ok so let's play let's play one more
then Cory today that's not that that's
crazy I couldn't even it didn't even get
to drink some tea
ah what the heck I was one of the worst
sequences ever not Queenie for Queenie
for you no I completely panicked
somehow that but the time was slow but
you get three seconds I actually attend
Sauk seconds on the clock
so really absolutely no reason for for
for panic mode
you
okay now let's go
okay a double of you and kiddo
yeah this is a pretty pretty bad line
for Blackpool just misplace your night
for no particular reason doesn't mean
that white wins immediately or something
but the night is just having a long
travel all over the board and at the end
of the day it doesn't have doesn't have
any we're good to go Jim
92 leads nowhere
five the heck is a five okay
I'd like to go if form just wonder
best way to prepare it might be
rookie 191 I'm going maybe 91
root can actually be useful on f1 if you
imagine later 4f4 coming can be can be
useful them
you
yeah seems he wants to play Bishop h3
let's go eform
and well okay we can take on G - don't
mind King takes
ah
you
something like is-6 probably
you
hmm interesting in a closed position I
would love to have the night on d3 form
in a later form but here he might take
and play Queen f5
so convincing actually
so I'm going to play a generally useful
move and then see what he does so he
takes
with the other pawn
you
yeah blacks position is indeed quite
reasonable I am must have made some kind
of inaccurate move
I mean like blood is not in great shape
but
much more out of the line like that
so it seems like he wants to go b5
prevent that for the moment attacking a
five
queen bee - now might be interesting
heck they have six night and if he
allows the trades and she has to
basically so I take
and 94 is going to be a factor now
stock squeeze deaf
a bit weak
isn't 94 problem here
[Music]
you
now if I go G for after three against
one of those miracle
wherever black needs a miracle to
survive
g4 is playing f5 year
crazy
you
you
I'm not sure maybe maybe it's still good
G for a five
I take age five if it takes e4
95 it could still be good
you
I still don't like this g4 f5 looks
extremely news
you
okay
as chief Wi-Fi was exactly the kind of
thing that I play and then screw up I
mean I know all my games often go you
have a good position anyway I mean what
kind of stuff is that and then you try
to refute the stuff and then yeah you
you overlook something silly and then
you lose happens to me so often
now this is clearly not winning yeah
so maybe I should have gone [ __ ] for
this stuff even though as I said I have
a history of playing stuff like this
like okay this looks like a clean
reputation and then I'm doing something
really stupid and loose
you
knight on f3 years should be
improved
I see just playing age six now yeah of
course
always the most ambitious move
can be tricky
you
yes his plate as well I mean
from that moment on many many Venice
position was really bad play well
I have to cover the night to know
move the King so that the knight can
move so I should have played that bloody
variation no matter if it is good or not
I mean I just couldn't evaluate it and
you just have to go for it if you think
it's the best
you
now this is nothing I'm not sure if
blacks better or something like that but
it's fear that I'm not better
you
you
you
[Music]
he's trying to surround my porn basic
claim
you
somehow a king maybe now the key cannot
move the king my idea is to play G form
you
if you would have taken on Detroit black
would be fine I mean does this might sir
be fine but it looks risky
stuff to get
how crazy is Jafar if it takes it
at the end night takes g-form
yeah it is pretty crazy
can i improve my knight Knight to f4
would be of course absolutely brilliant
you
now we can do this
I think if he goes d5a take with the
pawn Knight takes Queen a5 that this is
good for white I think
and taking with the Queen yeah
this feels extremely risky and again I'm
repeating myself
[Music]
Wow I didn't think that this is playable
at all
you
so it's putting himself into a self pin
here right
Knight c3 I would love to play where
they can take f3
so only 92
and now I have the check I can can take
it
way if I take it you can try to surround
throughout my porn
yeah
oh my
great game
and the show played f4 I have just
played this terribly really bad we were
able to play def for 495 I'm not sure
what this is and now he's winning this
pretty easily
as its got this additional weakness
there that he can that he can use
now not sure if this was best
a five is also midweek
to the coming nights you form
age - King G - Knight f3 he can play
it's night b7 at the end so it's doing
but it's doing the job so go back
so
five
you
you
you
scope a six
so it's that way for me to get the c5
porn is the problem don't see it
you
can take p3 has to take bathroom know
well that was a that was really not good
know what session is bad but there are a
couple of things that I really dislike
like if I get to get this position I
have to win the game
I really have to win it's just so so bad
yeah
Black is misplacing all his pieces and
it just sucks it's just bad chess and I
didn't review it
maybe I should go a3 first yeah I think
this is actually what I recommended
because this is totally bad
this is trapping the trapping his own
night and this is probably even better
because that a5 move helped them a
little bit I think
and now rookie 1.e4 that's that's one
thing but I mean again this is still
still very good but probably I just
didn't do it right so here
yeah I know it's a series of just like
slightly suboptimal moves that that gave
black the somewhat h3 is probably just
too slow okay but I mean I got a good
position just like this
now okay it's just a just plus three
plus three is this position and I simply
play it so terribly that I'm not winning
which is absolutely really awful so how
do we win how do we actually win the
winning move g4 does win so I could have
done that and I kind of saw that it's
good but I have this history of spoiling
positions like that where you think okay
he's doing everything wrong possible and
then you're trying to refute it with the
concrete line and then something
miraculous happens that save some so
okay the best move is this one which is
not completely clear to me why okay
hmmm this is a really cool line
I'm not really like I didn't see this
year and I'm not really ashamed of not
seeing this because this is extremely
cool queen h8 mate
or this one
okay so not fg5 okay I'm I'm happy to
concede that this is difficult to do at
least in this time control so f5
techniques takes I'm sorry
take C 495 that is what I saw and then I
saw Queen f5 and I was I don't know it
looks it looks odd but this is better
for white and more or less winning now I
was a little bit afraid here there's
like Queen f3 check but this is just a
check I'm threatening made on g7 so rook
here and now Queen e2 or takes here
takes and Queen e2 at the end of the day
it's playing without the night so I just
have to do this I okay I play the lame
move which is still a lot better for
white right here probably Knight c3 is
stronger and I could have taken only six
as well
this is this this this move don't quite
understand it yet so because I'm
probably getting everything here yeah I
get this and I get all the pawns yeah
that looks strong yeah auntie em thinks
things are things are okay for black I
thought you should you just should just
take on the two but okay this seems to
be right according to the computer
and t5
Knight takes thought looks crazy but it
seems to work and now I'm have to
improve I just panicked a little bit
here and I was but a bit frustrated
about the way the game went 94 or seems
correct couldn't quite see what happens
after this move but I can just play e7
here it only has one reasonable check
and then there's not much more going on
okay yeah of course this endgame is lost
but somehow I saved it this was it this
was this was just like ah how low you
just have to play h4 or f4 he end and
stopped g5 this is actually equal
according to the comp and now it's okay
0.1 so an all-around awful game and him
here f4 actually saves some yeah okay we
did we didn't have much time here
probably there there also still some
mistakes in five
should take h2
and this is actually already a draw I
can take on c5 I don't know why I didn't
this is very silly
it is already a draw oh this is not a
draw I should just take 93 okay I'm in
time man I'm in time this is again the
draw
wow that was a really bad game so this
was not the best session ever really
didn't feel fresh at all all right I'll
be back tomorrow I guess maybe with
another one of those sessions or
something else we'll see what happens
thanks a lot for watching